Welcome to the deep dive.
Today we're plunging into a
topic that's definitely been
making waves.
You might have seen it a recent
article using some really strong
language terms like
concentration camps and slave
labor right here in America.
And it's specifically talking
about migrants.
And honestly, just seeing that
phrasing, it really stopped me
in my tracks, made me think,
wait, what's going on here?
I imagine your reaction
listening right now is probably
similar.
Horror.
Maybe.
Disbelief.
Anger.
Even absolutely.
And that kind of visceral
response, that shock or outrage,
it's completely understandable.
It's human.
But what we really need to
wrestle with in this deep dive,
based on our sources, is
something maybe colder, more
unsettling.
Well, the article frames it like
an alarm, like these horrors are
looming, something new we might
be sliding into.
But the challenge from our main
source today is that this isn't
really new at all.
The argument is that this is
actually a fundamental,
persistent reality, something
woven into the fabric of America
from, well, basically the
beginning.
What's being described today?
The camp, the cage, the person
forced to work in the field, the
source says.
This isn't some recent
invention.
It's, and I'm quoting here the
Republic's inheritance, a route
that has never truly been cut
away.
Wow.
OK, The Republic's inheritance,
that's that's a heavy statement.
It suggests a continuous.
Line exactly an unbroken lineage
of certain practices.
So for you, our listener, what's
the mission here?
What are you going to get from
sticking with us on this?
Well, think of this as a
shortcut, a way to understand
these surprising, often frankly
uncomfortable connections.
Historical.
Economic the tie together these
crises that feel so new.
We're going to unpack how these
systems, systems of force,
labor, cheap labor haven't just
disappeared.
They've adapted, they've
evolved, persisted right from
the foundations of the US up to,
well, right now.
And doing that hopefully
challenges some core
assumptions, you know,
assumptions about freedom in
this country and what it
actually cost to maintain it.
Right.
And to do this, we're leaning
heavily on a specific critical
analysis.
Its title, All your Camps are
belong to US.
Quite a title it is, and it
comes with this incredibly
detailed appendix.
It's packed with historical
context, different viewpoints,
counter arguments, and some
pretty stark statistics that
really jive the points home.
So let's get into it.
Let's start this deep dive.
OK, so let's start with this
core idea from the source
material, something it calls the
debt chain.
The argument is that the basic
way unfree labor works, using
debt, using coercion, it hasn't
vanished.
It's just changed its shape over
the centuries.
Can you break down what the
source means by this debt chain,
this sort of invisible Ledger
that it claims is driving an
economy based on unfree labor?
Yeah, and it's really striking
how clear the source is on this.
It insists this isn't just a
metaphor.
It's presented as a Direct Line,
an actual functioning economic
principle that continues through
time.
To really get it, you kind of
have to think back.
Think about, say, sharecropping
after the Civil War.
You had black families,
technically free, right?
But they were completely tied to
the landowner.
Through debt for supplies tools.
Tools, seed, housing, even food,
all advanced by the planter, all
recorded meticulously in his
Ledger, usually at inflated
prices designed so the debt
could never realistically be
paid off.
And if they tried to leave?
Arrested.
Charged with debt, peonage.
That's the chain.
Now, Fast forward, the source
argues.
That same fundamental mechanism,
that inescapable Ledger of debt,
it now binds the migrant.
How so?
Someone trying to cross the
border, often out of sheer
economic desperation.
They usually have to make a deal
with a coyote, maybe a cartel,
sometimes a labor broker
promising work.
And these deals aren't cheap.
Not at all.
Exorbitant fees right away.
This creates a huge, often
spiraling debt.
A debt that feels impossible to
escape.
And these facilitators, they
hold immense power.
They enable the journey.
They promised the job that debt
becomes the lock.
Locking them into what exactly?
Into a precarious dependent
situation.
The source calls this the Ledger
that drives the invisible
economy, an economy powered by
and again, I'm quoting the
unfree hand that picks the food
that kills the chicken that
cleans the hotel toilet.
The debt ensures the labor stays
cheap because the worker isn't
truly free.
They're controlled by that
crushing weight.
An invisible Ledger driving the
economy.
That's a deeply unsettling
image.
But you know, when you see these
headlines about detention
centers, the initial article
talking about concentration
camps, it's tempting to see them
as maybe isolated failures or
something separate.
But the source connects them
directly to the system, doesn't
it?
It argues these facilities have
a specific function within this
whole debt chain logic.
What's the economic thinking
there?
Well, connecting it back, the
argument is that these centers
primarily exist to manage what
the source terms surplus labor.
It sounds cold, but think about
it in terms of supply and demand
for cheap labor.
If your economy relies on lots
of easily exploitable workers,
you need to control that supply.
Too many people, maybe wages
slightly rise or conditions
improve.
Too few production stops.
These facilities, the argument
goes, act like a holding pen.
A holding pen, yeah, ensuring
there's always a pool of
available, vulnerable workers
ready, but without flooding the
market or driving up labor costs
for employers.
And crucially, the threat of
removal, being deported, sent
back, just disappearing into the
system that keeps the labor
force compliant docile.
So the threat keeps them docile.
And the debt, as we just talked
about, keeps them cheap.
It's presented as a brutally
efficient system for controlling
labor.
And the source draws that stark
line.
The same system once used, the
auction block, today uses a
border checkpoint.
The logic is unchanged.
It's not about the building's
name.
It's about the underlying
economic purpose.
Control the labor supply.
That parallel auction block to
border checkpoint, it really
forces you to look past the
surface, doesn't it?
To see the economic machinery
under the headlines.
So if this invisible economy is
real, what does that mean for
you, For you listening?
You're just going about your day
at the grocery store, checking
into a hotel.
It really pushes us to ask a
hard question.
I think about the things we buy,
the services we use.
Do we ever really ask about the
full cost, not just the price
tag?
The human cost.
Exactly.
The source is blunt.
The unfree hand that picks the
fruit that kills the chicken
that cleans the hotel toilet.
Think about those surprisingly
cheap berries, That very
affordable hotel room, The
restaurant meal that seems like
a steal.
We just see the final product.
Right, These aren't abstract
concepts.
This is, the source argues,
fundamental to how so many
things become so affordable and
accessible in our daily lives.
It's an economy designed maybe
to be out of freight, out of
mine.
We enjoy the benefits, the
harvest, without confronting how
it was produced.
That's the invisible economy,
convenience and low prices built
on a hidden human cost.
OK, that idea of the invisible
Ledger, the debt chain, it's a
lot to take in.
But as you said, the source
insists this isn't new.
It's the latest version of
something much older, right?
Part of this long, unbroken
line?
Absolutely.
Can you walk us through that
history, the precedents that
show this continuity starting
way back?
Yeah, it's really crucial
context because the source
argues what we see today isn't
some sudden break from American
ideals, but more like an
evolution, a continuation of
these deeply embedded systems of
getting labor for cheap or for
free through coercion.
Each era kind of build on the
last or repurpose the old tools.
The appendix and the source lays
this out meticulously.
OK, so where do we start the
absolute foundation?
Chattel slavery, roughly 1619 to
1865 and the number is just
staggering.
The source sites 12.5 million
Africans forcibly transported
about 400,000 ending up in North
America.
Yeah, we know the horror, the
brutality, but what's the key
economic point for this
discussion?
Right beyond the undeniable
human tragedy, the.
Core economic take away is how
utterly fundamental it was.
The source states the economy to
the South fundamentally depended
on free labor for cotton,
tobacco, sugar.
This wasn't just some social
system existing alongside the
economy, it was the economic
engine for a huge part of the
country.
Especially cotton.
It was white gold.
It fueled southern plantations,
yes, but also northern textile
mills, Global trade.
British factories depended on
American cotton.
Northern banks financed the
plantations.
Insurance companies literally
insured enslaved people as
property.
So it was deeply integrated
nationwide, even worldwide.
Absolutely integral.
This immense wealth, this power,
was built on free labor.
It wasn't just tolerated, it was
economically essential for
centuries.
The scale of that reliance is
hard to overstate.
OK, so that's the foundation.
Then the Civil War happens.
Slavery is abolished.
Supposedly we enter
Reconstruction in 1865 to 1877,
and the source points to this
13th Amendment loophole.
The amendment abolishes slavery,
accepts.
As punishment for crime, that
tiny phrase.
And that became a massive
loophole.
How?
How do you go from abolishing
slavery to basically re
enslaving people legally?
It raises that exact question,
doesn't it?
How does the society pivot like
that without actually changing
the underlying economic drive?
The source explains that almost
immediately, Southern states
passed these laws called Black
Codes.
Right, I've heard of.
Those they criminalize things
specifically targeting newly
freed black people.
Things like vagrancy, just being
unemployed or homeless, petty
theft, even things like speaking
too loudly in public.
So they could arrest people for
almost anything.
Pretty much.
And once arrested, often on
flimsy charges, they could be
sentenced to labor and the
states would then lease these
convicts out to private
companies.
Lease them out like renting
people.
Exactly to railroads, mines,
lumber camps, plantations again.
And the conditions in these
convict lease camps were, as the
source notes, often worse than
slavery.
Worse.
How could it be worse?
Because the company leasing the
convict had 0 long term
investment in them.
Unlike an enslaved person who
represented a capital
investment, a lease convict was
just disposable.
If they died from overwork or
abuse, the company could just
lease another one.
That's horrific.
The statistics are grim.
By 1890, the source says, 90% of
Alabama's convict lease
population was black.
It was a direct, legally
sanctioned way to maintain a
cheap, controllable workforce,
just under a different name.
Chilling.
And that leads right into the
next phase.
The source discusses peonage and
sharecropping roughly 1870s into
the 1940s.
So the physical chains are maybe
gone, but debt steps in as the
new chain.
Precisely.
Peonage debt bondage was
technically outlawed in 1867,
but the reality it's arrived.
For decades, well into the 20th
century, both black
sharecroppers and many poor
white farmers got trapped.
How did that work on the ground?
They need to borrow from the
landowner for everything
supplies, rent, food from the
company, store, often a crazy
high interest rates.
Then, come harvest time, their
share of the crop was almost
never enough to cover the debt.
So they were always behind,
always behind.
Trapped in a cycle they couldn't
escape.
And it wasn't just economic
pressure.
There was violence, intimidation
and the local legal system,
courts, sheriff's was usually
stacked against them.
So the law backed up the debt.
Absolutely.
This source talks about the
overseers Ledger replacing the
physical whip, the economic
structure itself, the debt, the
legal vulnerability.
That was the control mechanism.
People couldn't leave and the
fact that the US was still
prosecuting peonage cases in the
1940s, it just shows how deep
rooted this system was.
Incredible how these things just
morph.
OK, let's jump forward a bit.
The Bracero program, 1942 to
1964.
This sounds different.
A legal government program
bringing in Mexican workers
during World War 2 because of
Labor shortages.
Right on paper it looks formal,
regulated.
But the source says it was still
exploitative.
How does a legal program become
coercive?
It's a key example of how
legality doesn't equal equal
fairness or freedom.
The program brought in millions,
4.6 million contracts over its
lifetime.
Huge scale, but even though it
was legal, it was plagued with
problems.
Like what?
Rampant underpayment, wages
often below what was promised,
constant threat of deportation
for complaining or stepping out
of line, terrible working
conditions, poor housing and
crucially, workers were
typically tied to one specific
employer.
So no power to negotiate or
leave for a better job.
Exactly that guest worker status
itself created vulnerability.
They knew complaining could mean
being sent back immediately,
losing everything.
So even with an illegal
framework you had this inherent
coercion built in.
They were highly exploitable
with very little real recourse.
So even government programs can
perpetuate this.
OK, let's bring it closer to our
time.
Mass incarceration and prison
labor starting around the 1980s
exploding since then.
US prison population skyrockets
500,000 in 1982 / 2,000,000.
Now how does this connect back
to unfree labor?
It connects directly back to
that 13th Amendment loophole.
Slavery is OK as punishment for
crime.
The source argues.
This loophole has fueled a
massive billion dollar plus
prison industry.
Billion dollar.
Incarcerated people are often
forced to work compelled labor
and they earn pennies an hour.
The average sided is around
$0.52.
Some states pay as low as 2
cents an hour or nothing at all.
Pennies an hour.
And refusing to work isn't
really an option.
It often leads to punishment,
solitary confinement, losing
privileges, maybe even affecting
their sentence length and.
What kind of work are they
doing?
All sorts of things.
Making license plates,
furniture, working in call
Centers for private companies,
even agricultural work, growing
food that ends up in our supply
chains.
It's a modern version of convict
leasing, essentially legally
sanctioned, unfree labor
directly tied to the massive
growth in the prison population
and the economic incentives
behind locking people up.
And that brings us right up to
the present with migrant debt
chains and border detention,
which the source dates from
around 1996 onwards.
This feels like we're all these
historical threads really
converge.
It really does seem that way,
yeah.
The source traces this current
phase back to things like NAFTA,
the North American Free Trade
Agreement in the mid 90s.
How did trade agreement lead to
this?
Well, LAFTA had complex effects,
but one major 1, was devastating
for many small farmers in
Mexico, especially corn farmers.
US agricultural imports, often
subsidized, flooded in the
Mexican market.
Undercutting local prices.
Exactly.
Millions of rural Mexicans lost
their livelihoods, pushing them
N desperate for work, any work.
This desperation created the
market for coyotes and cartels,
the smuggling networks.
Who then charge huge fees.
Creating those massive binding
debts we talked about earlier,
jets enforced by fear, by
threats.
So you have the economic push,
the debt trap.
And then the detention
infrastructure on the US side,
right?
And that infrastructure wasn't
built overnight.
The source points out that the
capacity for mass detention grew
significantly during the 2000s.
It specifically mentions the
Obama administration, which
oversaw record deportations,
around 3 million people and
significantly expanded detention
facilities.
So the infrastructure was
already scaling up, yes.
The argument is that later
administrations inherited and
then further expanded this
existing scaffold.
So what feels new in, say, 2025
is described by the source as
the same scaffold, only scaled
and branded.
These current camps, the
detention centers, they're built
squarely on this long,
continuous history of managing,
controlling and exploiting
vulnerable labor.
The logic, the source insists,
hasn't really changed for
centuries.
Wow.
OK, that historical context is
it's a lot.
It really paints a picture of
continuity, and it sets up this
next really provocative section
from the source, which it calls
the good Master's paradox.
The original article we
mentioned, the one using terms
like concentration camps, it had
the sort of hopeful note, right?
That decent Americans would see
this rise up.
Boycott companies refuse to
benefit, right?
The cult of mural action.
But our source threw some cold
water on that idea, doesn't it?
It has a much more challenging
take on this Moral Majority.
It really does.
It offers a pretty sobering
counter argument.
It basically says this Moral
Majority, these decent
Americans, are in fundamental
ways, quietly complicit.
Why?
Because they consistently
benefit from the system, the
source puts a bluntly.
They are the same quiet
multitude that eats because the
fields are filled by the unpaid,
the underpaid, the never to be
legal.
There's a disconnect, it argues.
A disconnect.
Between the outrage at the
visible cruelty, like kids in
cages hitting the headlines,
which is genuinely horrifying
and sparks a real human
response, and the unwillingness
to look deeper, the source says.
People protest that visible
horror, but they never ask why a
father separated must work twice
as long for half the wage, so
that the cage remains an
exception of the rule.
So the outrage focuses on the
symptom, not the 'cause.
That's the argument.
The analysis is that the a good
master, this decent American
protest, the obvious cruelty,
the lash, the cage.
But they don't really question
or confront the harvest, the
underlying exploitation that
makes their food cheap, their
lives comfortable.
And this leads to that really
striking line you mentioned
earlier.
The plantation never burned.
It was renamed.
What does that mean here?
What are the new fences of this
renamed plantation?
It's maybe one of the core
arguments.
It means the basic structure of
exploitation didn't vanish with
slavery.
It just adapted, got new names,
new legal justifications, a new.
Look, So what are the new
fences?
They aren't always literal
barbed wire, though that exists
too, the source argues.
The key fences now are often
invisible lines, the line
between undocumented and
documented, between a detainee
and their kids outside who still
need support, between someone
with legal status and someone
without.
Creating vulnerability.
Exactly.
A permanent state of
vulnerability and fear that
ensures there's always this
exploitable workforce available.
And it allows, the source
suggests, for moral outrage to
be neat and contained.
You protest a visible cage, feel
good about it, but don't have to
change your consumption habits.
You avoid facing the stained
cost of your abundance, the
daily benefit you get from the
system.
That's a tough.
Idea to grapple with, especially
because you often hear the
opposite concern, right?
Like the original article warned
that mass deportations could
cause a serious labor shortage,
hurting the economy.
Yes.
The economic impact argument.
But our source reads that
concern very differently, much
more bluntly.
Oh, absolutely.
It basically calls that labor
shortage fear, the quiet part.
Spoken aloud, it cuts right
through the economic jargon to
what it sees as the core truth.
It's a starkly Without our
illegals, we have no slaves.
Without our slaves, the economy
we cherish does not function.
Wow.
That equates illegals with
slurs.
That's strong.
It's incredibly strong and it's
presented not as name calling,
but as the fact beneath the
field and economic reality
check.
Think about the stats of the
USDA estimates 5050, maybe 70%
of US farm workers are
undocumented.
So removing them would.
It would cause chaos, collapse
entire sectors, agriculture,
hospitality, construction worth
hundreds of billions.
The source draws that parallel
again.
Southern plantation owners
before the Civil War were in a
way more honest.
They just said it.
Emancipation will destroy us
because their economy depended
on slave labor.
And today?
Today, the source argues, we
talk about reform, compassion,
worker protection, but we rarely
propose changes that would truly
sever the overseers chain of
debt and fear.
Why?
Because the economic hit would
be too big, too inconvenient for
the good master for us.
OK, let's talk about those
images again.
The kids in cages, they have
such a powerful, visceral
impact.
They spark immediate outrage.
Understandably so.
But the source argues this
visible image, however horrible,
is just the tip of the iceberg,
just one part of a much bigger,
more insidious structure.
That's exactly right.
The source stresses that these
images are only the visible face
of an architecture that cages
entire families in a permanent
shadow.
The real cage, the argument
goes, the more pervasive 1 is
the legal cage, the one you do
not photograph.
What does that mean?
The legal cage you do not
photograph.
It refers to the constant
background hum of fear and
cruelty that the system depends
on.
It thrives because people are
too terrified to demand their
rights to ask for fair wages, to
report abuse.
Their silence, their compliance,
is necessary for the system to
function smoothly and cheaply.
And that fear is the cage.
That constant fear of
deportation, of losing
everything, of retribution,
that's the invisible cage, often
more effective than actual bars.
Can you give us some more
concrete examples?
What does this invisible cage
look like for real people
day-to-day, beyond the news
photos?
Sure.
Imagine.
Imagine a mother working in the
fields, maybe picking
strawberries in California.
She owes a huge debt to the
person who smuggled her across
the border.
She knows they can threaten her
family back home or reported IC
at any moment.
So she just keeps quiet and
works.
Keeps quiet, endures grueling
work for wages that barely cover
anything because speaking up
feels too dangerous.
That's an invisible cage.
Or think about a father working
construction.
The boss isn't paying overtime.
The equipment is unsafe, but his
family's entire stability, their
kids schooling, the money they
send home depends on this job.
So we can't risk rocking the
boat.
He stays silent.
He indoors.
That's another invisible cage,
and the source stresses this
isn't just a few bad apples, a
few cruel bosses.
It's systemic.
It's the constant, necessary
cruelty of a system that depends
on people too terrified to ask
for what they're owed.
Their vulnerability is the
point.
It's what makes the labor cheap
and controllable.
It's a feature, not a bug.
Systemic necessary cruelty.
That's a hard concept, and it
leads us to some common
questions that come up whenever
these topics are discussed.
The source actually tackles some
of these directly.
First off, that term,
concentration camps.
It's so loaded.
Are these ICE detention centers
really concentration camps?
Yeah, the source, just careful
here, it says technically, no,
they aren't concentration camps
in this specific historical
sense of, say, Nazi death camps
designed for genocide or even
political prisons in the same
way they detain people based on
civil immigration violations.
But it immediately adds their
scale, extrajudicial nature, and
potential for forced labor
ecosystems of mass internment.
It suggests a closer historical
parallel within the US is the
internment of Japanese Americans
during World War 2.
Right, 120,000 people, mostly
citizens, locked up.
Exactly so while the ultimate
purpose might differ from
Auschwitz, the basic idea of
mass detention outside the
normal judicial process, with
potential for abuse and unfree
labor, That pattern, the source
argues, has historical roots in
America.
OK, that's important nuance.
What about family separation?
Those images from the border
were so shocking.
Was that unique to one
administration or is it broader?
The source is very clear.
No, it's not unique.
It's systemic, deeply embedded.
It points out that over 100,000
kids get separated from parents
every year just through the
regular US criminal justice
system. 100,000 How?
Think about it.
A parent gets arrested, jailed,
put on probation with strict
conditions, deported for a
crime.
The kid often ends up separated.
Foster care relatives, state
custody.
The focus on the border, while
highlighting specific awful
policies, sometimes hides this
much larger ongoing issue of
family separation within our own
domestic systems.
That's a staggering number.
And it also notes, remember
those kids in cages photos that
went viral in 2018?
Many of those were actually
taken back in 2014, which shows
the practice, the infrastructure
for detaining kids like that was
already in place.
It wasn't brand new.
It's entrenched.
OK.
And the final big question
really cutting to the core of
this deep dive, is debt bondage
really slavery?
Here the source, backed by
international consensus, says
unequivocally yes.
It points out that the UN, the
International Labor
Organization, all the major anti
trafficking groups, they all
classified debt bondage as
modern slavery.
Why?
What's the defining factor if
not literal chains?
The key is that the workers do
not have meaningful freedom to
leave.
The debt itself, combined with
threats, maybe violence, lack of
legal options, maybe having
their documents withheld, it
traps them.
They can't just walk away.
They're in servitude.
And chillingly, the source
states this is the most common
form of modern slavery worldwide
today, affecting millions.
OK, this really brings us to the
uncomfortable question of our
own role, our complicity.
People try to make moral
choices, right?
You hear pledges.
I won't buy from that company,
the one that uses detained
labor.
Right, the attempt to vote with
your wallet.
But the source seems to suggest
that's, well, maybe not enough,
or maybe missing the point.
It definitely challenges that
approach.
It asks essentially.
So we signed pledges.
We will not buy from the company
that exploits the detained OK,
but we will buy from the company
that exploits the invisible.
The invisible.
Meaning the debt slave in the
orchard, the bonded day laborer
on the construction site, the
unpaid girl in the restaurant
basement who owes her coyote
more than her life is worth.
The argument is our moral
outrage often focuses on the
contained visible cruelty.
The photo, the news story we can
react to and.
Ignore the rest.
And meanwhile, the pervasive,
unseen exploitation that might
be making our everyday goods
cheaper, our services more
convenient, that gets a pass.
It's ignored, rationalized away.
It's a challenge to our
selective vision, really.
So if we were serious, if we
really wanted to dismantle this
whole thing, not just the cages
we see, but the whole
architecture of coercion, what
would actual freedom accost us?
Yeah, what's the price tag on
genuine freedom for everyone
involved?
The source argues it would mean
a radical shift.
It says if we truly meant
freedom, freedom from fear,
freedom from debt, freedom from
the overseers Ledger, it would
fundamentally alter our economy.
It would mean, quote, paying the
full price for the fruit, the
roof, the meal.
Prices for many things would
likely go up noticeably because
that hidden subsidy of exploited
later would be gone.
But it's more than just prices.
Right.
Much more.
It would mean granting these
workers real status, bargaining
power, legal wages that reflect
the real value of the work.
It means being willing to
dismantle not just the cage you
can see, but the chain you
choose not to.
It forces us to confront how
much we benefit from the current
system and ask if we're willing
to change our economic reality
for their freedom.
Which brings up those common
pushbacks like the classic well,
why don't Americans just take
these jobs then?
The source tackles that head on.
It says sometimes Americans do
take these jobs, especially when
times are tough, but crucially,
not at the same wages or under
the same threats.
That's the key difference.
Legal status, having rights,
having recourse, being able to
quit and find another job
without fearing deportation or
violence from a smuggler that
brings bargaining power, The
source implies.
The labor shortage isn't really
a shortage of people willing to
work, it's a shortage of people
willing to work under the deeply
exploitative, unfree conditions
that this vulnerable workforce
currently endures.
OK.
And the follow up question, So
would fair wages fix it if
everyone just got paid properly?
It's part of the solution, but
it circles right back to that
paradox.
Fair wages mean higher prices,
right?
And this is where it gets really
uncomfortable.
The argument is that the same
people protesting the visible
cruelty often resist paying the
higher prices that fair labor
would require.
They want the moral high ground
and the cheap goods.
A plantation paradox again.
Exactly wanting to.
Condemn the cruelty without
giving up the economic benefits
derived from the system that
creates it.
It holds up a mirror to our own
consumer choices and their real
world impact.
And this is where the source.
Delivers its final, really stark
take away, a thought that forces
some deep reflection.
It says your panic is not that
it might come.
Your panic is that it might be
named for it is, and that you
might be forced to see your
share.
And it's harvest.
Yeah, that lands.
Hard, doesn't it?
It reframes our fear.
It suggests the real anxiety
isn't about some potential
future horror.
It's about acknowledging what's
already here, what's always been
here, often hidden just beneath
the surface, and our part in it
and our part.
In benefiting from.
It the source concludes America,
America, you do not fear the
camps.
You fear the freedom that would
cost you what you are unwilling
to give.
It's a profound challenge to our
priorities.
What do we value more?
Human dignity and real freedom,
or cheap stuff and economic
ease?
It suggests our deepest fear
isn't a new monster appearing,
but having the old one named,
seeing how it sustains us, and
then being asked to actually pay
the price to slay it.
Hashtag Ted Care outro.
So let's try to wrap up this
deep.
Dive We started this jarring
article about concentration
camps and slave labor affecting
migrants today, but our sources
have shown us this isn't really
new.
It's It's the latest chapter in
a very long, very American
story, a continuous line.
Right.
An unbroken.
Thread of economic reliance on
labor that is unfree or coerced
or just incredibly cheap because
of vulnerability.
The debt chain didn't break the
overseer just changed form.
The plantation essentially got
renamed adapted for modern.
Times and understanding this
history.
This continuity, it's not about
pointing fingers or assigning
blame to individuals today.
It's about, well, it's about
clear eyed recognition, seeing a
persistent reality that shapes
our economy, shapes our lives in
ways we might not normally see,
and that recognition leaves us.
With a final thought, a
challenge really, for you, the
listener, to take away.
It's absolutely right to be
outraged by cruelty to protest
the visible cages, but the
source pushes us further beyond
just asking who built the fence.
Ask.
Who profits ask?
Who profits from the labor?
Behind it and whether you will
pay the price of tearing it
down, not just the physical
fence but the whole system,
that's a powerful.
And yeah, necessary question to
end with.
We really encourage you to
continue your own deep dive
after this.
Maybe just look around
differently, notice the cost of
things, think about the labor
behind the services you use
everyday.
What small shift in perspective
might you have now knowing this
deeper, longer story?
What might you see that you
didn't?
See before exactly.
Thank you for joining us on this
deep dive into something that's
both a heavy historical truth
and a very present, very real
part of our world today.